gone to enable you folk to uh you have a
reasonable break what time does council
start okay three or three okay cool yeah
two right yeah so we we do have a
reasonably full agenda uh we do have a
we do have some external
guests in the form of um uh our our
retiring auditor and our new auditor
um and uh we have a reasonably full
agenda so we'll we'll keep pushing on
um and see what we get to we are live
streams now and if anybody
um is watching welcome to the meeting
Mel I've got to check do we have any
counselors
um uh that are on screen as well no it's
just those that are present here that's
great
um
uh we're good to go then so can I um
deal first up with uh apologies we have
a um an apology as I'm probably sure
everybody know knows from knobby uh he's
not here anybody else
able to stay here for the meeting that's
good I'll move from the chair that
nobby's thank you grant put the motion
all those in favor please say aye goes
against
it's carried
for some reason sorry my system is not
liking me here
thank you can we uh blue please to the
minutes the last meeting how it was on
the last meeting
21st of March meeting minutes
no sorry can I just back the tracker
I've just got to get my computer system
right again right are there any matters
of interest that people needed to clear
for the course of the meeting anything's
going to affect them there isn't no I
haven't been informed of any public
forum which is great now we can deal
with the minutes of the 21st of March
I'll move from the chair that the
octagons are true and correct record
we'll have a second but please thank you
Lucy is any com is there any comment on
those
thank you to the staff that have
followed up on all the action items on
those there's a fair bit around health
and safety and we've got a fair bit on
health and safety Andrew and team coming
up in the meeting which I appreciate
that
um and I think the rest is being dealt
with I'll put the motion that the true
and correct all those in favor please
say aye aye those against it's carried
can we uh then move please to the
minutes of our meeting of last
Monday is it the 15th was isn't it
um uh the extraordinary meeting of the
risk and Assurance committee again I'll
move from the chair that they've taken
to the true and correct record thank you
Ross there's any debate on those
accuracy
um or correctness
there'd be none I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye aye those
against us Carrie thank you we moved in
on to item six which is the um uh The
Joint pcbu Judy is a very nice one thank
you Andrew appreciate your presence
buddy
um I think he was chair just take the
report pretty much as read just to put
it back into context the councilors
might remember this issue came up as
part of the approval for some road
closures and then an ongoing discussion
that was raised around
council's obligations where roads are
closed for events and then more broadly
council's obligations where events occur
or indeed work is undertaken on any
um parts of land owned or occupied by
Council and the the overlapping duties
that might arise in those circumstances
at that stage we indicated that a report
would come back just to highlight what
those overlapping Duties are and where
they might arise I've done a little bit
of work in that space as the report sort
of highlights and I suppose from a
council perspective the key message that
I'm trying to get across in the risk
space
both to this committee and back through
to the organization is that whatever
approach we take it should be consistent
across all aspects of the organization
and so uh to a certain extent this
report might seem to be a little bit
critical but it's critical at a council
level not necessarily at an individual
area level because there's some areas
that have thought about what they do in
this space
whether or not it's two counts with risk
appetite is a different question but
they are doing good work in that space
as far as they have been instructed by
Council but I think what the report's
highlighting is that across the
organization we need to be consistent
and probably need to be more aware of
these risks and how we're managing them
so if you've got any questions in
relation to that thank you Andrew it was
a very always revealing to read and also
actually I appreciate you including the
relative the real the real examples of
both ficari and Tim's coromandel
in the collapsed um
bouncy castle or whatever it was it was
something more than a bouncy castle okay
do we have questions Foundry yes rangi
thank you chair look
um I want to raise the issue of traffic
management
and and how it applies to obviously we
do a lot of Road works
and it appears to me just looking at the
traffic management
installations currently in place for the
work that's being done it seems to have
gone to an extreme over the top sort of
management an example is D Street
there's some pipe work being done the
ranks home pipeline by the church
and yet the traffic management plan
extends
all the way just shy of Herbert Street
blocking off businesses
on the east side there's the Z petrol
station and the tire place and I'm just
wondering this is this is sort of
you know there's there's 800 meters of
clear space that that for some reason
um
well it seems like 800 I need to measure
it but uh it seems an over design
um for what's actually being done I
can't quite understand that so do we
how do we work with our contractors to
say woo you know we don't want to shut
down
the city
at the highest level I suppose this
paper highlights how we work with them
we work out who's best managed best
place to manage the risk and that person
undertakes the work that they think is
appropriate to manage the risk
um and it is an issue that comes up sort
of to your point but almost a different
way and we need to be careful and this
paper tries to highlight
if we were to manage workplace health
and safety with every contractor or
party with whom we work we would have
20 or 30 staff just trying to manage
Health Workplace health and safety and
so in many respects what you're talking
about there is a there's a traffic
management planning Place done by the
contractor we don't double guess whether
or not that is correct or not because
they're the best place to manage that
risk and so if we were to go in and say
to that contractor we think you should
do it differently then that is Council
taking on the risk and the management of
workplace health and safety in that
space and that's not something that we
would ordinarily step into well another
reason I'd say we would get involved is
because we represent theoretically the
the governance here the people the the
owners of those businesses and we would
have to say well
on their behalf is this necessary you
know prove to us that it is necessary to
to do the work way down here you you're
shutting off
accessed everything way down here
to me it just doesn't quite make sense
and and as is there other reasons or is
it an overreaction to safety have we got
to a stage of overreacting
I don't know whether uh rangi that's
actually an easy question to to answer I
think I think I'll ask easy questions I
pardon I'm not here to ask easy
questions no no I appreciate that but I
didn't I'm I'm not I'm not certain uh if
I've heard the answer correctly
that actually isn't directly for ICC to
determine in this case crew okay so it's
the it's the person I mean this is the
point of the paper yeah it's the it is
the the
um the contractor presumably in this
position who is best place to determine
what is safe and they will be
accountable for it we have over
overlapping responsibility I agreed I
don't disagree with that I'm talking
about the overlap but
but I think actually Andrew said it
actually you have to be careful as to
you what what is the first role in terms
of overlapping duties according to the
paper it is
who is best place to make the call yeah
that's what I've read from the paper and
I think the point you're making in the
case of D Street and I agree I got I was
affected by that today rangi it was is
actually it's the contractor is best
placed
Michael I think you've got a point and
then I've got Grant and then Ria and
then
then go through YouTube I just wanted to
remind councilors that um in relation to
Road Corridor access we play two roles
in relation to that we actually have to
sign off the um the road access
requirements
under the requirements of wakotahi so
they have changed their um their
approach to a risk-based approach so
they do assess each of those wrist
plants and we're we're the
administrating body in relation to
signing those off so they have come
through Council from that perspective
but
just the difference I guess in this this
approach is we've got to see the
guidelines from what kotahi that we need
to uphold in relation to reviewing those
plans from a and it is a risk-based
health and safety approach that they are
focusing on
so for because it's a state highway they
get involved as a third party yeah the
contractor
us
and Waka katahi
through yourself chair what kotahi is
always involved in relation to Road
Safety access plans where we are
administering their regardless of State
Highway or not correct that is correct
okay
right I've then got a grant please yeah
so just a couple of things thanks to you
just maybe to ring his point it's just
simply that we
um ensure that the contractors take
account of the impact on businesses that
can be a simple resolution to that but I
didn't want to spend time on that it was
regards to when
um we would receive if you make comment
around ICC to assess
um controls across the areas identified
and report to this committee when when
are we likely to receive those I think
it's really important then we have very
clear timelines around when we're
receiving stuff so that there's we get
stuff done and we know it doesn't get
lost
I agree
um
I'm always a form of a description
sucker for over committing
um I have at a high level looked at what
we do I would expect I can let you know
at a high level what we do at the next
meeting uh as for
working and getting alignment across the
organization that will obviously be a
longer piece of work but in terms of a
high level summary of across the
different parts of the organization the
approach we're taking and and where we
see an immediate defect if there is any
changes that we might have made the next
committee meeting you'd be able to get
that back it's because again it's one of
those issues once we've identified the
issue we can't sit on it no and so
um we're at risk if we think there's a
failure in our systems at the moment so
we need to work on that fairly quickly
yeah I think it'd be important to see a
time frame and if that needs to be
extended or but at least we can get some
assurance that we're making progress
towards understanding our risk and
having measures in place to prevent
wherever possible I wonder Andrew if
under the PX item we've got health and
safety again as well which is good which
is more abrasive about in a follow-up
and in effect to the
recently next discussion we had at the
last meeting around health and safety
Grant I wonder if you could just keep
that in your mind and we we bring that
up at that stage not because I want to
necessary be in Peaks but actually
that's where we've got a strong review a
look at okay it's more comprehensive
view across our across our health and
safety and I think that would be useful
Maria oh thank you Mr chair um Corona
Germany basically asked my question
right thank you Tom
Andrew the the paper
um
focuses on the health and safety of work
act and her role as a pcbu and
accountabilities that could flow from
that
but it but it also in several places
talks about Public Safety
am I writing this a question I don't
know am I right in thinking that
actually Public Safety is a different
obligation that we have does not fall
under the health and safety workout so
for example if a child fell on the
playground and and a playground and was
injured
um does that fall under the health and
safety work actors is there a separate
legislation
users of your facilities are deemed to
be you have a an obligation to anyone
who attends your workplace whether or
not they're there necessarily as a
worker or not does that make sense and
it's where it becomes quite
you know a mental context quite
difficult because you don't perceive
those people to be uh and it's the same
issue we have with contractors
contractors such as workers under the
act and it's defined as people who you
have a duty to provide a safe workplace
so anywhere where you have workers
effectively the ACT covers and so people
who come onto that workplace and become
covered by the air so there is no
separate legislation that's there's no
separate legislation there's common law
with your duties but no act that says I
ever obviously got a duty as you do on
your own home to people who come there
and get injured or whatever but there's
no legislation specifically covering
that okay thank you I think that that
reflects um like that team's coromandel
case Tom
where that was a contractor making or an
event promoter making use of public land
under permission from Council Council on
the land and all of a sudden the child
the person
but is on the is on the land is affected
and then there's a prosecution
so yes it is a challenging area hmm
thank you for that um if you have any
other questions from folk yes Ria I'm
sorry I've just got a little um thing
going off the back of my head so with
that
um scenario you just gave us
um with the scenario being here in
invercargill at the water found at the
water fountain where um that's legally
being mucked around workless soap sides
and what have you in a small child Falls
in there and drowns who's responsible
for that yeah so again you saw that case
in the paper and quite clearly that's a
council Duty and it would be covered
effectively under whether or not the
health and start is civil duties
obviously but we've recovered under the
health and safety at work whether or not
we've done everything we're required to
and to be fair we did do some work on
that and we have got ongoing work and
and it's part of the role of this
committee to sort of look forward and
see what our risks may be so when there
was the the uh terrible incident in Gore
we went and reviewed a lot of our
waterways and all our waterways and and
so again as part of this we'll go back
and review it and say look here's
instantly occurred somewhere else
yes we know people use it we're not as
far as I'm aware but we will have to
investigate whether or not aware of
aware of similar sort of risks in terms
of people getting in there or falling in
there and if we are then we'd have to
consider what we would do so you see
that there's been some work done on that
prior
um so at the stage now where's that at
for the for that Fountain oh we didn't
should something happen tomorrow are we
we didn't necessarily I can't tell you
whether we looked at the fountain in
particularly we looked at all our
waterways um we and we had a discussion
around our roles their duties and and
where they fall because obviously
there's a lot of exposable ways
invercargill
um and so as much as anything
we will go back because of this incident
and look at our fountains again I
suspect more specifically
um but we did look at it broadly this is
highlighted a different scenario we will
go back and look again and see where
we're at
thank you that's very interesting
um can I I I can't help but observe that
gets us back to what's our risk appetite
if we had no if we had no risk if we had
a totally adverse appetite towards risk
would take our fountains out oh yes
Darren just following on from The
Fountains it goes right down to um as
Andrew mentioned all waterways and and
then would find ourselves having to
mitigate against the
[Music]
Thompson's bush
well you know that I've always been
there so there's got to be a degree of
common sense that's that's measured in
as well and and and responsibility
but we asked the question what else
could we do
is there anything reasonable
and that's the degree we've got to look
at thank you Darren well thank you for
that Andrew I think that's uh that that
it's very Illuminating and very helpful
as we go down our health and safety
further down a health and safety Journey
um uh so look we um I don't want us to
lose your point
um Grant I think that's something we'll
come back to when it when when we're in
the PX paper so we're going to receive
the report we note the overlapping
duties we note that we will receive
um further information on the current
state of maturity regarding our
obligations and we note that the risk
and Assurance committee will receive
reports on incidences involving
overlapping duties as part of normal
health and safety reporting let somebody
prepared to move that and second there
please
thank you I saw Rhea I saw Tom and thank
you for the rest that also offered uh
there's any debate on the motion
I've been none I've put all those in
favor please say aye aye against this
carried thank you
the verbal item I think uh at the stage
on quarterly risk yes again through your
chair and apologize I didn't put
anything in writing but it's
it's contemplating where I think we're
at uh and where I think this committee
uh can add some value to the
organization I think
um
just broadly speaking there's a number
of risks that are occurring both
externally and internally within the
organization at the moment they're
putting
pressure on the way we do things and I
think I suppose what I'd like to
highlight is I think this committee
needs to start or I would like this
committee to start looking a little bit
more forward-looking we tend to be
um reacting to re to things a lot um and
I think this committee through the
long-term plan and a few of those other
things has a bit of an opportunity to
want a better description get ahead of
the game a little bit I think we we're
seeing things coming up and we're not
necessarily planning for
um how those might play out or how they
might change and and having in place
um appropriate controls or or
consideration around what we do when
those risks are realized and I think
that's leading us a little bit exposed
in in a number of areas where we're
seeming to be and having to be reactive
because we haven't really thought
through our process and our steps as
well as we would like and I think that's
um
I suppose what I'd like to highlight
we're going through that as part of a
long-term plan process in terms of
making a lot of assumptions and I think
it's key that that this committee
understand the impact of those
assumptions and think about if those
assumptions don't pan out the way that
we hope they will
um what that means for us what we're
going to do what's for one of Michael's
description the plan BCD because I think
we're we're not necessarily seeing that
at the moment it'd be my overall comment
I think around where we're at obviously
in the maturity space we've seen papers
coming up we're trying to improve the
maturity we've got a strong focus on
health and safety at the moment and I
think that's starting to pay dividends
and and as I will discuss that in the
public excluded not because it all needs
to be publicly excluded but there are
parts of that paper that touch on things
that shouldn't be in public and so we
can release that paper afterwards if the
committee so desires but I think we've
got a bit more work to do in the more
General space to try and leverage those
gains in health and safety and try and
improve the organization more generally
but I'm happy to take any questions or
yes Grant so
um I agree what I meant just to
understand how the officers help us
achieve that
I think a key I mean from from my
perspective and again I get myself in
trouble but but I think it's another key
point that I want to make about this
committee this committee needs to be
able to be independent
um and I think I said this to I've
definitely said it to staff and I'm sure
I said that the council is in their
induction this committee needs to be
able to challenge both sides
um and so
if I was being uh
in my comment in that space would be
that staff need to be able to get away
from management to a certain extent
um I think one of the risks or one of
the well it's a risk one of the issues
whatever you want to say that we have
around staff being able to give better
guidance to counselors in that broader
strategic context is that they're too
embedded in the doing and it's difficult
for them to get their head up to be able
to give you the the bigger picture
advice because they're they're stuck
with the doing and
um I think that it's not a question of
capacity it's a question of do they have
the time and space to be able to start
to give you that more forward-looking
advice when we're just reacting to
things all the time
um and so that would be my my comment
and so we're trying to and I know
Michael's trying to we're trying to
clear up room for that to occur and once
that starts to occur then you'll start
to see those papers I suspect coming
through
okay he's got second red soaps
so and unless we understand our health
you know health and safety risk
within our business how possibly can we
look forward strategically in what i s
I'm hearing and whether I'm hearing it
wrong is that we don't fully have a good
grasp of what our current environment
looks like we've got bits and pieces
that we've got some clearer
see through on whatever risk is and
other parts that are you know almost
impossible for us to understand so my
pointers and until we see and what I
understand is how will we offices enable
us to be able to see a current
environment
and then when we can see that clearly
then I think we can look forward with
the benefit of applying
um legislation and near misses and other
entities and those sorts of things or
councils you know how would we that
landscape but I'm not confident that we
have a very a clear view in a starting
point for us to be able to assist their
risk when we don't have that clear view
at the start and and I suppose in the
answer that I think you're starting to
see that in the the health and safety
report we do have data we do collect
data I mean it's it's the old statement
isn't it uh in God we trust everyone
else bring data we're we're trying to
create those papers and that ability to
have those decisions and have those
conversations and I think you see that
quite clearly in the shift in the new
paper
um obviously we've got work going on in
the background where we're trying to
effectively get the one organization
model in the background so getting that
data together is easier but in the
interim we're working with what we've
got and we're improving that data
collection even though it might be
manual even though it might be a number
of different sources to try and improve
the decision making and the guidance
that we're able to give you in that
space
thank you uh Leslie and then Tom
Mr chair Andrew
you mentioned assumptions that we're
making
surely we're already being alerted when
we make any assumptions for the
long-term plan to the possible risks of
those are you indicating that needs
beefed up from the alerting that's
already
present
yes and no and and I've had this
conversation because we do tell you when
those assumptions aren't holding true
but we never go back and say
what was the risk we identified if those
assumptions changed what were we going
to do what was our mitigation so if we
make a whole assumption around interest
rates then obviously we realize interest
rates it's a big assumption or inflation
or whatever
we don't really map out and say okay if
we're wrong on that
what does that mean what are we going to
do what are we thinking about and then
when it comes up and and in finance and
wherever else it comes up which it does
we don't come back to risk and say what
was our plan around this we sort of just
go oh well that's happened on we go we
haven't sort of got to that point where
we're actually ahead of the game and
saying well once that happens these are
the sort of levers that we'll pull this
is what we'll do we just get forced into
a situation where we pull them it's not
say they're right or wrong
but if we were more risk mature we would
have already thought through that and
we'd have our strategy in place we
wouldn't be sitting around the table
saying oh we need to find x amount of
dollars which one are we going to plot
we would have already thought
if this occurs this is our plan these
are some options that we will go through
we'd just be a little bit more
sophisticated around it it's not that
we're not doing the work at the outset I
think it's more that Loop background to
when our assumptions don't hold true
what are we going to do and then working
through that a bit more methodically
than I think we do at the moment it
happens
but it almost is happening
by chance is the wrong word it's just
happening in the absence of a real
playing around it I suppose it'd be my
comments
Okay so
you're saying to some extent what we
need is a closing of the circle
is that something that you would suggest
we should
do the moment we have those
risks highlighted against the
assumptions we're making sure are you
saying that should be the trigger for us
to go that extra step
so implicit in any plan is a whole heap
of assumptions that and and and part of
risk management is to ensure that we
achieve our our outcomes and part of
that is to try and hold us within our
assumptions as best we can someone will
always change but if if our assumptions
changed then we may or may not need to
change your plan
and we hear and tell you that the
assumptions or that our assumptions are
no longer valid but we don't necessarily
go back and immediately say what does
that mean for our plan to achieve the
outcomes we wanted
and so as soon as as soon as we vary
from the Assumption we made it should
loop back and there should be a
discussion what does that mean are we
going to change anything what do we need
to do because our assumption has proven
wrong
um does that make sense okay and then
there's some real key assumptions we
make that then and look it's part of one
of my gripes around a long-term plan
more generally we make this plan and
then we put it on the Shelf we we do a
lot of work
to make all these assumptions when we
build our plan do you know what they are
have you ever seen them again no no I'm
not being but but that's that's that
Loop we we our assumptions underpin
everything we're trying to do yet we
don't go back and say was our assumption
right
okay I think
Tom
Sandra I think that last discussion was
very helpful because
um I when you when you expressed the
concern and very very broad general
terms I must admit I was really
struggling to get the point
um
however I did observe that virtually
every paper which is which comes to this
board
sorry it comes to this Council includes
a risk statement
pretty much everyone includes a risk
statement surely that is a vehicle for
providing that kind of you know let's
see a range of possible outcomes and
provide that forward-looking opportunity
so I as I was listening to you I was
wondering what it was that you were
proposing that we do differently because
we already did that do you just think we
should do it better or
it's almost Loops back to my earlier
comment in response to council Germany
you see this but you see it in a
different context so when you're seeing
those risk statements at finance and
insurance or a council or wherever you
don't necessarily focus on actually on
the risk and and and it's again where I
started this committee its focus is risk
and so in terms of uh
really identifying and being able to
tease out those issues you are more
likely to get a better discussion here
yes they should be highlighted
everywhere but at certain times
significant changes this committee
should agree these are the sort of
things that should come back to us and
that's what the risk framework is trying
to do where things get to a certain
level of risk or or we're outside our
tolerance they come back to this
committee uh yes it would still be
highlighted in the other paper
but you won't necessarily get the same
discussion about them in that form
you're wrong
I just want to get back to health and
safety and and the safety of safety of
humans
um I just want to question the work safe
uh the work safe guideline thing you've
got attached in here
and it talks about
uh it talks about what does reasonably
practical mean and this is
the ways of
managing risk and it says here
you first do what is reasonable to
eliminate the risk if the risk can't be
eliminated then you must minimize it now
that acknowledges there is still a risk
and are we are we happy that a
contractor would still continue on a job
knowing there is risk because if it
turns pear-shaped
worksafe won't be going back to their
guideline and saying oh you know that
fell under that we won't prosecute you
they will be prosecuting us
because of that of that element of risk
so where do we sit on that do we what is
our tolerance when it comes
to this gray area that is identified
clearly in their own literature if the
risk can't be eliminated then you must
minimize it okay so you do all you can
to minimize it but it still acknowledges
that that risk is very much real
so do you just walk away and say no
we're not doing that job
because of the risk or do we proceed and
and play some music if it does go
it does go a bit bit wrong well I think
this comes back to the chairs comment
and and discussion we've been having for
some time around whether or not Council
has a risk appetite
for injuries at work let's put it that
way and the short answer is we must
um because we do things we can't
eliminate all risks
um and so it's a question of assessing
what is reasonable
um and there's there's guidance there's
lots of reviews around it but noting
that the primary obligation is to
eliminate the risk and so again we need
to challenge ourselves
um around what is necessary and what we
should do to eliminate the risk it's
only once you can't do that that it
becomes what you then do subsequently
and I think often people miss that step
um but the the ACT is quite clear it's
eliminate first and only if you can't
eliminate should you then accept have a
tolerance for an ongoing risk but that
puts us in that prosecution area clearly
[Music]
because what they would say is that you
know we both say us and the contractor
we did everything to minimize it but
obviously we didn't do enough because
the the mistake wouldn't have occurred
or the accident wouldn't have happened
and then I mean
you're in a you're in a no-win situation
and and I suppose and this is a as a
litigator I will tell you this is what
white Island highlights for you if the
consequences in the same with Pike River
if the consequences are severe enough
then what you're expected to have done
will be more
um so what is expected to be done where
you have a risk that someone breaks
their finger versus the risk that
someone dies is very different and and
it's understanding back to councilor
dermody's point it's understanding what
your risks actually are which then lets
you make that informed decision as to
how much effort you should take so where
does our policy sit on making that call
on where uh it becomes from a broken
finger to a broken limb to uh to to to
death
so this is this Gap it's all around our
risk slash Hazard as they use in in
workplace health and safety assessment
and are we truly identifying what the
potential consequences are and if you
identify those correctly then you go
through the correct process so it's as
much as anything it's identifying the
appropriate consequences which triggers
what happens afterwards and so
theoretically if if death is one of the
consequences then that thing would not
proceed uh not until we had mitigated
the risk down so that there was
we can't always remove it and the
classic one that always gets used is
driving a car we can't remove the risk
that someone will die in a car accident
does that mean we don't drive cars
um I think that's simplifying a bit well
no no it's it's an easy one for people
to understand I can use any number of
examples but that's that's the reality
where you can't always remove the risk
of death but you still accept that you
have done as far as is reasonably
practicable what you can to reduce the
risk
right I'm conscious of time can I just
keep moving on please I've got Ria
Michael then Leslie thank you Mr chair
um Andrew
I'm am I here trying to understand
exactly where you're coming from and I
can kind of see the picture that you're
painting us
um am I right in saying you say that
this Council needs to act independently
we need to look at our risk and
assumptions should those assumptions not
pay off for us
are you identifying that you feel that
there is a skill Gap within this Council
to be able to fulfill the ability to
analyze the risk as we are live ongoing
because when you talk about mitigating
risk and the assumptions a lot of the
information that we make decisions on
are bought by
our officers
um a lot of us come from different
backgrounds we have a risk
um experience across the fields so
I'm trying to figure out where there
could be a possible solution to what
you're asking us
I think there's a skill Gap not at all I
mean Council does a lot of work the
assumptions are good don't get me wrong
um some of my question because they
imposed on us by the local government
process
um but it's more that we don't
then think about what changes and revise
our plan to achieve the outcome we're
after and that's what risk management
should help you do it's as much as it's
and and this is the other bit that I'm
trying to emphasize it's around
achieving outcomes as much as mitigating
risk I mean and we focus often on on
avoiding a risk whereas what I'm saying
is if we
sometimes Revisited our plans because
the assumptions have don't quite proven
to need to be amended we might then
change our path sooner
is I suppose what I'm highlighting
and it's not a it's not a lack of skill
it's it's just because the issues are
raised
but I what I'm challenging is whether or
not they're raised in a context that
enables you to have the right
conversation and that's why I'm saying
this committee because this committee is
around what's the risk okay we've got an
assumption The assumption's Proven false
what's that mean what are we going to do
that's what this committee thinks about
finance and Assurance is interest rates
have changed my budget's changed I
let's have a look at it listen it's just
a different Focus it's just it's a
subtly different lens and that's all I'm
really saying I think the issues have
been raised but I don't think they
necessarily come back
to this Committee in the right way
and particularly in that strategic space
I think this committee has been quite
um
risk management looking rather than
strategic objective focused
thank you Michael you've got a comment
yes um thank you through yourself chair
um just want to highlight two things one
about the roading side of it but what
kotahi has a zero harm policy in
relation to it and that's why their Road
management plans are quite excessive in
relation to that because they are
focusing on that it's
well they've got to approach they're
still going to be hum there's always
risk associated to everything and that's
why they try and minimize access into
those corridors when they're trying to
do the do those works but they can't
eliminate from that perspective
the other aspect is the council
tolerance level in relation to health
and safety and in fact most other risk
categories needs to needs to be
understood to give direction to staff on
what mitigation measures to put in place
because that does change I think today's
discussion from Andrews actually
highlighted in relation to health and
safety how far do you go because if it's
we've got no risk and and no tolerance
in relation to health and safety risk it
is remove remove the fountains that's
put everyone in bubble wrap Etc and I
know that's that's going to the extreme
and you wouldn't want to go to that
position because you can't operate so
it's what's acceptable level when do you
in
when do you say to staff you know we're
comfortable at that level that you're
monitoring to that's some of the
reporting that Andrew will be looking
for in the next written report in
relation to the party
um risk reporters what level is that
what tolerance is acceptable for Council
where do we pitch that and so you can
monitor that because that's what we need
from a operational point of view to be
coming through so then we can put in
those mitigation measures for you to say
if this risk becomes an issue this is
the mitigation measure that will kick
into action
hopefully we don't need to use those
mitigation measures and we just flow
through that risk doesn't get realized
and we end up with the end result that
we're after that's the ideal solution
I think the Highlight that Weasley
thanks Mr chair look I was just going to
make what I hope as a quick comment
um
and it sort of ties in with what Michael
has just said about levels what
councilor pottinger raised was the butt
for argument
but for the want of a nail on a
horseshoe the war was lost
but for the starting of the troop trains
at the beginning of World War One
if they hadn't been started there
wouldn't have been a first World War the
butt War argument leads into Infinite
regression you can always go back to
search for the nail that was missing
from the horseshoe or the point at which
someone started a troop train that then
couldn't be stopped
um
the the fact of the matter is
we have to be practical about what is
possible because if you take the back
four argument you would do nothing this
Council would do nothing because
everything would have
so much risk so many nails that needed
to be found that you would never start
any project at all we wouldn't start
here 12 25 project because there's the
possibility that a screw would be
missing from an rsj beam and that the
roof would collapse whatever
um so what it comes down to is if it
ever came to
prosecution
it is extremely rare to go back and look
for the nail
there are usually plenty of other points
at which the causation that led to the
accident or the death can be sheet at
home
um
to to say that the back four argument
should stop us doing anything becomes a
ridiculous proposition for any Council
we have to be reasonable about the level
of risk and as the ACT says where we can
eliminate do it where we can't mitigate
and yes look at all the possibilities
for mitigation try to make sure that you
have not left anything open but at the
end of the day come to a reasonable
point that is defensible and means your
project can keep going forward so sorry
to be a bit lengthy about it but the but
for argument would just completely end
our ability to do anything
thank you Lucy now Andrew can I just ask
a question please I'd like to wrap this
up because it was a verbal report and
where are we but uninformed
what's next I mean I'm to have a
quarterly risk report we don't start
with our tolerances we actually start
with what are the Strategic risks okay
and we we understand our current
environment
we understand why this stalls are
current strategic risks that we have
we look at what we're doing and we apply
them against our risk appetite are we
within our risk tolerance or not that's
where we've got to get ourselves too so
I'm I'm really giving you the
opportunity what's the road map from
here so that we have a discussion about
our actual risks applied against our
actual risk appetite and what are we
doing about it can I can you give me a
bit of confidence around what the road
happens again I would have written it
for this one but uh just was a matter of
making sure that was where this
committee wanted to go but we'll have a
report to that effect uh at the next
meeting talking about those issues and
and looking at some of those strategic
risks it's a little bit of a difficult
time because when the process reviewing
all our assumptions
and so at the moment our strategy is a
little bit
fluid for one of a better description
but to the extent that we can we'll
start to highlight some of those those
bigger ones that aren't going to be
impacted by our decisions around
projects so much we can start doing with
some of those underlying risks and where
we're sitting and the the risk maturity
is is to a certain extent following the
health and safety and we'll be able to
start getting some reporting on that
have a look at ones that are well and
truly outside our tolerance and what if
anything we're doing around that
that would be helpful thank you
right there were a couple of hands are
there questions that need to be asked or
can I look to receive Andrew's verbal
report
mine was just a comment just to reassure
counselor soaper that we're looking at
what joints not screws for the museum
okay oh well there we go brilliant thank
you grant okay can we move to the motion
please which is that we receive a very
helpful report from Andrew thank you Ria
thank you Tom I'll put the motion all
those in favor please say hi
thank you very much right
gentlemen at the back
Chris Derek I wonder if you're coming
forward as well but certainly you need
to Chris thank you and uh we'll move on
to the audit plan for
um uh the coming Financial year which is
which well it's the current plan for the
year that ends 30 June
so look uh folk it's great to have you
two here
um often it's on the screen and it's
tremendous to be able to to meet you
both in person
um many of you will recognize Derek on
my right and he's probably a bit of
whatever on yours dark suit has been our
auditor who gave the opinion on the last
few sets of annual reports and Chris on
his right is uh going to take over the
new audit and so consequently I think
Chris is probably correct to invite you
ultimately once I've invited Patricia to
make a couple of comments to speak to it
so thank you for being here both of you
uh Derek obviously we've got your
management report to hear about later on
which uh will be received as well so
Patricia anything you need to lead off
for like Chris do his thing
um it might be actually easier for Chris
actually lead off and then I'll sort of
chip in at the end because actually some
extent my comments are LED from the way
in which we are going to do the audit
this year I will say at the start though
that we are taking a a slightly
different approach and looking to mainly
since we have to come back to a 31
October
um adoption day that is the statutory
deadline for adoption for Council is the
31st of October and for ccos is the end
of September so the changes from the
last couple of years have been removed
um so I'll let Chris um
start and then I'll jump in at the end
just for something a bit different right
thank you appreciate that Chris open to
you uh welcome to the Betty thank you
thank you Patricia
um
around the table but not to all so I I'm
Chris obviously and you're appointed
order for going forward
um
why I say I'm not a familiar face to
Summers because I've been supporting
Derek for the last two years in the
avocado City involved with the Holdings
companies and centuries so a bit of
experience within the group yeah
um in terms of what's in the paper
Patricia your covering paper is
have as much of the things I want to
talk to so it's quite helpful
um as particular outline there is three
letters you would normally expect from
us this year
now those are the order plan which is in
your next that outlines the risks and
issues the audit in their areas of focus
the audit engagement letter which is
outlines my responsibilities is the
appointed auditor and the council's
responsibilities for the audit as well
and the audit proposal letter which is
the one you've commonly refer to as the
B leader which outlines our hours and it
will be the third one is not there it's
currently the fee is currently
undergoing and what a rationing
processary General and it comes to the
next meeting
um in terms of what is in your picks the
Order Plan itself
that's probably worth briefly talking to
the first three risks in the plan yeah
possibly just touching on some standard
changes that are willing to plan as well
which is highlight those to you
so in terms of the first risk um the one
meter is the caring value of puppy plant
and Equipment
um this is a common risk that you see
within the sector and you've probably
seen it before in terms of the global
city council but really this is about
the risk where you have revented assets
and you don't value them in one year and
this is about looking at whether we're
assessing those uh essays that they are
materially similar to the value they
would be had you value them
so at the moment management of provided
an assessment around this and we're
working in engaging on this early
looking at that and I think nutrition
facts and paper that um eroding
evaluation responsibility there
um if we do get to that conclusion that
had they been valued it would be
materially different from What They
carried out triggers an off-cycle
revaluation which is weird which is
coming from
um
I think that you know the key point
there is reviewing that early and giving
sufficient time should a revaluation
need at them excuse me Chris that would
be rude here can you just pull the
microphone closer to your mouth please
uh your lovely uh dolls at tones but
we'd like to capture them please if
that's possible thank you can you softly
spoken as well so I'll get close
um also within that risk I touch on the
prior qualification and saying that
there will still be there and but in a
reduced form in relation to the
comparatives and solely to the
evaluation movement but it's a prior
issue just just washing its way through
um the second one there on page 32 talks
about group accounting and consolidation
probably the key thing there is around
consistency of accounting and looking at
the group as a whole and ensuring that
things are accounted for and measured in
the same way so the key point that we
sort of drill down on that is within the
invercargill central limited assets and
making sure that they are held at a
value that's consistent with the way
Council accounts for things
and also briefly the touch from the
paper on bus person related
applications in relation to the loan
should any assumption or input to that
loan change and that number of current
the laboratory Council mostly
um part of the third risk is one that
you've um seen from us before as well
which is the affordable water reform
um it's packaged in terms of the new
form of of the reforms but you know
still a significant reform and still has
a significant impact on on Council
services so again this is flagging that
we're expecting disclosure of the known
impacts of the reform at stress known
um and
um highlighting that we're likely to
emphasize that in the form of an
ecosystematic paragraph like we have
previously that's just the year to
um highlights two readers there's an
important measure that they should
understand when they're ready
so that's what it's lagging
um I also briefly touched on a couple of
standard changes um the first one there
is on page 33 which is the first time
adoption of a service performance
reporting standards
and there's some points there in terms
of some additional reporting obligations
that arise as of this year
um those are probably
um why this is a risk versus a risk
because you know anything new is is
prone to error and it's just just with
anything
um but the key sort of new obligations
there are around documenting the
judgments when you're sort of measuring
or defining things like you would for
financial information
but equally also about trying to improve
comparability so that you're able to
look at performance over time as well
just just trying to get that
comparability up in terms of performance
reporting and the third one is really
important and provides really important
information to users which is about the
linkages between financial and
non-financial information
um
and why I say that's important to users
is it's really about tying in that look
at what a service costs
um but equally how it's gone so you can
look at the input variables above what's
gone into providing the service and then
the output of how that's gone just
trying to tie that through the flavor of
your annual report which is which I
think is a good move in terms of the
standard
the second standard change
I'll find the page is on page 40 refers
to a new auditing standard
uh this is ISO nz315 and this is just a
highlighting here that this is coming in
effect to us this changes the way we do
certain things particularly around our
risk assessment and documentation of
internal control
um greater has a greater emphasis on
internal control documentation but
equally I.T as well there's some
additional risk factors that we need to
document here as well and determine what
risks will see
so that's just highlighting the work
will be different and more in that space
um
also in your pack is the audit
engagement visa and as mentioned before
that is just outlining those various
responsibilities of both of us I don't
propose to go through that in any great
detail and take that one as a reason
thank you Chris appreciate that
appreciate any coins
um my comments are probably more about
the date so for the awareness of the
committee we are the um we have already
started the work as Chris said we've
started the work on the fair value of
assets and that has been partially
audited already
um we have an interim starting straight
after King's birthday for two weeks
which is longer than we have for the
last two years with a typically been a
four day and from audit and we're trying
to front load a lot of the testing work
into that period on the basis that we
should have more staff available
fingers crossed on that one the final
audit
um starting in the 18th of September
um and the audit plan notes there will
be eight to ten Auditors most weeks
during that period just for the
awareness of the committee that is more
Auditors than we have accountants
so the capacity strain that is goes on
to the finance team during that period
is significant given that that is when
we're also doing the main budgeting for
the ltp
so there will be uh pressure
um points so we're we're working through
we I have got Plan B C D are we up to e
yeah maybe
um so we have got some plans around how
we'll do it so um
that is pressure This Is Not Unusual in
the sector just that we're at the end
because we're adopting on 31 October
that puts more pressure on us so we are
trying to front load some of the ltp
stuff or free people to only do our DP
so you're only doing ltp or you're only
doing annual report
um to do that but just from an awareness
and with other change from prior years
is that we have asked for more Auditors
to be physically present
um and invercargill for longer so that
we don't have audit by email
I don't know okay thank you very much
today appreciate that and Chris thank
you for that that update so um I do have
probably three key areas I'd just like
to get some Assurance on Patricia before
we go through it but I wonder if members
you have any questions we have two
documents in front of us the plan and
the engagement letter we have any
questions
East Ross and then Grant
I'm encouraged with the forward planning
in resource so I presume that's for both
sides and agreed
um and I guess we know the issues up
front although there will be some that
will arise as the course of the order
because nothing ever goes smoothly but
I'm a sure I'm reassured that we have
adequate resource and planning this year
to meet deadlines
Mike Ross Grant yeah similar to Ross's
coming thanks to you probably the theme
of the audit that late last year and
hopefully this year's work with us so
um you know that dialogue through an
order was valuable in terms of providing
additional information required or if
the information is not quite up to spec
so it's great that you've resourced it
and hopefully and that's my other
question is just around
I've noted your comment around the
pressure that's on our staff both with
the ltp in this and
um we'll look for some reassurances not
only from you but from Michael that you
know we have fully resourcing this area
because it's a very important place for
us to get both those pieces right both
their audit and also air
air um forward budgets so we need to
make sure we're across there
right I had um uh sorry
there were I guess three key points that
I I was after one it's obviously the
timetable and you guys have hit and I'm
looking at both you Patricia and also
you Chris have had a chance to work
through that this is
achievable
um and it does mean that we've got a
meeting already members on the 35th
October by the sounds of it
um I do want us to take into account and
we've seen this a couple of times from
the mayor which is quite reasonable I
think he was here I think I could
sponsor his view it wouldn't be that
good though if we were meeting both as a
committee Anders Council on the same day
I think we know that that is a view so I
just wonder whether we've taken it into
account number one
um
look I'm comfortable with the level of
pre-planning and that's tremendous
I think one question that this committee
must answer on behalf of council
is actually that the form and nature of
the actual proposed annual report is
right
so if we're only getting to see it on
the uh in the agenda packs it is too
late for us to any fit and effect change
um uh so to look to get a sense of the
shape and the feel
um and I'm looking your way Patricia it
wouldn't be unreasonable the committee
sees some form of pro forma
about how we intend to report it will be
absent the numbers it'll be absent the
performance measures
but it might have the tenor the nature
of what we want to say and I'd like you
to just um I'm imposing work on you but
I would like us as a committee to do it
properly and have a chance to see a pro
forma which gives a chance for this
committee to have input to actually
this is the way we want to account for
ourselves that make a lot of sense
um
two things that I have taken out of last
year and I just want to
um check
the matter of the accounting for ICL
if I've got it correctly and the loans
and the asset
really tripped us up I was going to say
last year she was this year
it wasn't that unfortunately so my my
concern is is and again I'm looking your
way Patricia and Michael
are we looking abrasively and
comprehensively
at our transactions and looking at them
from an accounting implication
perspective now I will admit ICL was an
incredibly technical
series of issues
but we're doing 12 25. if we got out we
thought now about what do we do about
any work in progress
that we thought about the implications
of its impairment
I'm wanting to to to encourage
management to look at the transactions
we do from an end-to-end perspective not
just what number do we slot into the
into the annual report so I'm looking
for a level of assurance
that we not only are doing things like
the fear valuation but we are looking at
those key transactions that occur so
that can be something that we can have a
a chat about but I would be I would be
Keen to see that we do Chris the
critical thing that I learned from last
year
amongst other things was doing stuff at
the right time
so I'm hearing encouraging noises that
you already have some awareness of the
fear evaluation
steps that we've taken and you have got
the time and probably yourself you're
the opinion Giver to look at that now
I've obviously Frank afforded uh front
foot of those other risks there that
we're talking about and some of those
accounting issues so just trying to do
things at the right time great that's
good
okay in the timetable sits there so
we've got that so look I'm I'm
comfortable with it
um we have the engagement letter
you're right it's a it's pretty standard
but um members I would just encourage
you
to recognize that we are committing to
doing a lot of things in that letter
it isn't just saying what the what the
auditor will do it's actually indicating
that we effectively are committed to
good open transparency and that we will
provide Chris in the Auditors with all
that we know
okay so it's a slightly solemn thing and
we've got a role to recommend that the
chair does that now Chris the third one
is obviously would normally expect the
fee
and if I was being uncharitable I would
characterize your asses to sign up to a
contract without knowing the cost
um and that is a difficult position in
one sense to be in
you've indicated that fees are likely to
rise
can you give me any indication
I'd not like to be a judge a moderation
process because I think I can talk about
the reasons why fears would rise but I
wouldn't want to rejection well could
you give us an idea of why fees will go
up I think it's reasonable that that I'm
happy to pursue and I'm not going to
covenants that we don't unless I I think
we need to pass these resolutions but I
would like to have some idea
about why our fees are going up thinking
yeah so it's a historical matter but
equally also looking at everyone at the
same time so in terms of fees in the
sector I think it was flagged around
class to be around around eight
growing under recovery of all of these
over a period of time
and they're leading up to a point at
which the pandemic came into place at
that point in time the AG made a
pragmatic call to not take care
um move at that point in time and
effectively put a pause on on increases
at that time since that time we're
seeing increased complexity increased
standard changes and more expectations
suppose last standard cities as well as
additional Skype items too
so it really is is this historic pause
for the included and rather things come
in
and it's just to understand that
okay thank you for that um I'm not going
to ask you as you say to surmise what
the fee might be um but uh Ross you you
are I don't know I'm I'm taking Chris at
his good word he's given us a strong
indication for you to guard up yeah and
I understand that from Professional
Services firms and and the reasons the
other part to that though is efficiency
in the way Planet so it doesn't balloon
out in the extra time so you know I
would hope that the fee isn't more than
the last year's fee plus the extra that
has been agreed and I'm
again not holding to anything but I
wouldn't um
I want to see if more than that combined
level yes thank you that does actually
raise a really good point Ross which is
is I mean we're trying to do two things
with this audit process Chris one is
that we do the right work at the right
time
but I also think we need to make certain
that we are we are maximizing the
efficiencies that are at all possible in
the process and I know that might be
counterintuitive we could say well let's
go back to dashboard and emails but
that's not the way to do a proper order
as we know so I hear that Leslie I think
you have a point oh thank
you chair I was just
just give a percentage indication
there must be
there must be some
um some at least thought and audit's
mind about the percentage of extra
complexity work that you think is going
to increase the theme
as an upper level are you talking about
a 10 increase or 20 increase
I still don't want to prejudge
admiration position
um especially a benchmarks
yeah I can give you information but I
think I'm best to give you the right
information
all right
thank you Chris appreciate that
um obviously the the and I don't want to
put Chris in a difficult position that's
fine
um but elsewhere the fees are
substantial Rises and Chris's point is
that actually we're dealing here with
um a parliamentary parliamentary
expectation that audites pay the full
cost of fees they're not subsidized by
the taxpayer I think that's another
point that is behind what you're saying
uh and you're indicating that that the
auditor general feels he's held feeds
back for probably the thick end of about
four years rather than having hit the uh
the gradual increase
I think the critical thing Chris is that
we
have a good audit
because that will minimize our fees
rather than the the issue which we will
debate later demands for extra fees
that's where we get it yes Tom
sorry but I guess it's stately obvious
but I mean to the extent that you are
able to influence the process through
the process of moderation at your
describing
um I mean I think as a council you know
we we've got to observes that we are
doing things like not cutting the grass
as often
um we're cutting the grass
higher than we previously did I mean I'm
just giving you one example of is that
we're trying to reduce the inflation
impact on repairs
um so although we run a business too
where it'd be great to be able to just
run a Cost Plus so we don't
um so I'm hoping that when you get to
that moderation process you know you you
build those things in mind
I mean I could give you a list as long
as the Army things that we're doing to
try to reduce their cost
thank you Tom appreciate that and that's
a key message that I I still think in
the middle of this as we have made our
plans that I would want to be assured
that we have we have you know it's easy
you can try for me to say it returned
everything
figure out what is what's done okay folk
I think I'd like to keep moving unless
there's there's more questions people
like to raise we have in front of us as
I said two documents two of the three
that we normally have
um the engagement letter plus also the
on the the the the uh annual plan so
um uh we are receiving the report we're
noting um the detailed
plan will allow us to report by 31
October there's ongoing communication
and of course that's been critical for
us around actually getting near the fair
value assessment uh we have noted there
is the new standard frs48 again this
comes back to the reason why a pro
formal would be great to have and that
we note that the fee for
23-25 is still to be received and we're
saying the next meeting that we have so
that we've got
um and uh importantly we have a role to
recommend that the mere signs the
engagement letter
do I have a movement I think that so
it's all there it's a lot of thank you
Tom thank you Leslie he's thinking about
debate on the motion
there'd be none I'll put it all those in
favor please say aye aye aye those
against us Gary thank you very much
thanks you gentlemen we'll get you back
in the PX later on appreciate your time
thank you
right reminder
right so it's time for us to move uh the
motion to uh go under public excluded
um uh and I will just find it we have
quite a number of uh matters a through I
um the agenda sets out the reasons why
from the chair I'll move that we go
under PX but I have a second to please
thank you grant is it any debate
on the motion oh sorry and I also need
to include in that grant that we allow
Derek and and uh Chris to stay as well
too please by the way sorry I shouldn't
always take that as thank you Michael
keep me safe
um that we'll include that in the motion
there's any debate on that motion
there is none I'll put it all those in
favor please say aye aye's against us
Carrie thank you very much